[Music]
terry joins us up next in austin terry
welcome to the show
hey how's it going guys thanks for
having me great how can we help
um
tell me how to get myself out of this
giant hole that i've dug
describe the hole
well um i've been looking over the
numbers and i'm showing i'm right at
thirty seven thousand five hundred
dollars in credit card debt um
if i add my s well credit cards my car
and then if i add student loans that
adds about forty five thousand to it it
adds 45 so what's the total amount of
debt
yes uh student loans and credit cards as
right under 80 000 like 77 000 okay
what's your income
uh right now it's about 45 000 40 to 45
000 a year okay what's up what's the car
worth
um i just got the car a couple months
ago um
so honestly i could probably sell it for
maybe
three grand less than i paid for it how
much would that be
um i show right at 20 uh right at 30
thousand dollars
sell it sell it immediately today this
weekend go on um
well the issue i have no issues
no issues just sell it just sell it just
sell it
it's my source of income though
your car is your source of income
yes describe that
um so
i was working doordash full time um
making about fifteen hundred dollars a
week okay um and then the car that i had
which was paid off
in my name it i blew a hole in the block
and i went a month without being able to
get work or do anything because i lived
in the
20 miles from town
um so i went out and got this car
because it's easier to walk into a
dealership and get a car with no money
than it is to walk into you know a shop
and get your car fixed with no money
and my plan was to get rid of like after
i get my debt squared away fix my old
car and didn't get rid of this car
terry here's the deal man i'm trying to
make the money there's there's no reason
you had to go out and get a 30 000 car
making 40 grand all in the name of i do
doordash
what are you doing brother
so we can help you get out of debt all
day but we gotta get to the root i know
you're trying to get by man
you're just digging the hole making it
deeper and deeper deeper but i know it
feels like you got to be running because
you're scared and i get that man but you
got to stop okay stop
so
terry what was the credit card debt in
you had 37 000 what was what were the
purchases
um
it's just
usually paying bills and stuff to get by
um
like i said 30 grand of that is the car
if i exclude the car it's
closer to five grand okay well selling
the car is going to clean this up you
need to find a way to produce more
income it may not be doordash maybe a
career change to start making 50 60 70
even if it's for a short time get after
it but this is gonna take some intense
sacrifice it's gonna have to take a
mindset shift where you go
debt is not an option anymore
no more thirty thousand dollars get a
five thousand dollar car man
and i want you to feel the sacrifice and
it's not gonna feel good but when you're
debt-free you will say this was 100
worth it and we can get a nicer car
later when we have the money for it